since the novel coronavirus first showed
up in america
in january 2020 the u.s government has
routinely impeded
scientists and public health officials
from coping with the covet 19 pandemic
early on the surgeon general admonished
americans for buying masks
you do not need to wear a medical mask
like this one
people should not be walking around with
masks you're sure of it because people
are listening really no
close there's no reason to be walking
around with a mask as recently as last
august the centers for disease control
and prevention
said people without symptoms don't
necessarily need a test
the food and drug administration stood
in the way as independent labs worked to
quickly develop
covid tests and it wasn't until this
spring that the agency
finally approved an at-home test you
could get without a prescription
but what about operation warp speed
which even critics of the trump
administration praised for speeding up
the development of covet 19 vaccines
government money
isn't what brought us to the point of
ending the pandemic via a new way of
developing vaccines
messenger rna vaccines and a
revolutionary new technology for dealing
with future pandemics
was underway long before operation warp
speed came into being
the horrors of the last year spurred
humanity to quickly develop an
unprecedentedly flexible and powerful
toolkit
that may well make covid19 the last true
pandemic
writes reasoned science correspondent
ronald bailey
in his new cover story for the magazine
the amazing thing is
we'll be able to forestall any further
pandemics in the future because
so many advancements in vaccines
treatments and so forth have come out of
that now you can just slip
any piece of genetic information into
that lipid and you now have a vaccine
the covet vaccines have not only proven
to be safe they came much faster than
predicted
we hope to russia to be able to have
some impact
on recycling in the next season
and like i said that could be a year to
a year and a half i'm not changing
any of the dates but here's the really
astonishing thing
almost all of the time that it did take
to bring the vaccines to market
was due to safety testing and other
governmental mandate by january 13
2020 only two days after the chinese
researchers shared the genetic sequence
of the covid19 virus the biotech company
moderna
had devised the formula for its vaccine
tech launched its covet 19 vaccine
program in january
and had partnered with pfizer to
manufacture it by
mid-march of last year the first
volunteer was injected with modernist
vaccine on march 16 2020
yet it was only approved by the fda last
december 17th
a week after pfizer's vaccine met the
agency's approval we have the model of
being able to do this
it's plug and play if we have another
virus
comes along we'll be able to identify
very quickly
genetics necessary to just plug it into
the base of the vaccine and you could
roll it out within three to four months
as opposed to a year
that the covid vaccines have proven safe
in clinical trials as strong evidence
that future messenger rna vaccines will
also be safe as well if we have another
pandemic and another failure of this
regard it will be a policy failure the
technologies are there what we just have
to do is to have
our bureaucracies get out of the way and
let them be deployed in a
expeditious way had the agency been
faster off the mark and used human
challenge trials and
other innovative testing techniques the
vaccines could have been brought to
market
months earlier with no compromise in
safety
would the government allow a vaccine
based on this plug-and-play model
to be deployed not within months but in
a matter of weeks to stop the next
pandemic
in its tracks that's an open question